so i got a question on facebook recently
from one of my followers
andrew leong who wrote in to say hi evan
i follow your videos i love them
i'm just wondering what you use to
recommend it for an email platform
crm and email marketing and asked if i
could do a video on it
so you just won't learn this stuff in
school university i'm hooked
well thank you andrew welcome aboard to
the channel so in this video i wanted to
quickly show you the tools that i use
and hopefully you can learn from it so
for our
email point of view i use gmail i love
gmail i was on outlook for the longest
time
and i left outlook because
at the time my my outlook file was just
too big with the attachments
it took too long to load outlook and it
was slowing down my computer so much
that uh it became a big hassle and i
like the convenience of gmail being able
to log in from my home
from the office when i'm away easy to
get access to everything
i think outlook now you can get online
and all that but
i haven't used outlook for so many years
and i'm so comfortable with gmail that
this is uh what i like so one thing i'll
do is i'll email myself these videos so
that's why you see the message again
here twice
but one of my favorite tools if you guys
are using gmail is to get a tool called
rapportive
and if i click on let me click on bailey
if i click on somebody's face
their email what will happen is they'll
show me their information here
so if i get an email from bailey
now i know bailey well but if i didn't i
could see who she is i could see
how i can find her i can find her
twitter or linkedin if we're connected
or not what her google plus page is
recent emails and all that
so a really convenient tool to keep
track of
of who's sending you emails that i
really like within
gmail so it's called rapportive it's a
free plugin and
you can go check it out for email
newsletters i use
aweber this is my aweber page i've been
on aweber for years
like it pretty simple pretty easy to use
there's a lot of solutions out there
one of my favorite things with aweber is
it'll tell you for emails that go out
what is what the spam score is on it
so if you're creating an email blast and
it's going out to your audience it'll
tell you
what might cause people not to receive
the emails
which is great because you don't want
you know all that hard work you do in
creating your list
and then creating the content to just
have it stuck in somebody's spam folder
so that was one of my favorite features
i think a lot of them have it though i
don't know that there's that much
difference between the email clients
but this is the one that i use and then
for crm this is probably my most drastic
one of all i don't do
crm i don't follow up with people so i
don't need a crm system
it may be a radical approach
but i believe more in spending my time
on creating
amazing content for my audience and
being seen as the expert in my field
and if i do that enough then i get tons
of deals and people
come to me and so i've landed huge deals
with major corporations
from banks and telcos and software and
technology companies
and i've never reached out to them and i
don't do any follow-up
so i don't need a fancy crm program to
help me
instead i just focus my time on creating
amazing stuff that my audience cares
about
and as a result get tons of business
coming to me so it's a better use of my
time
the only thing that i do do is i've
created a list of uh
of people who i once a quarter try to do
something special for
so i have personal tds as a business
that i've invested in
business would be more of my team and
then clients from the past quarter and
i've kind of blocked those out just for
uh
for purpose of this video but basically
what i'll try to do is once a quarter
find
something fun to do for them just as a
way to
stay in touch and say thank you um
recently i hired
a a guy on fiverr to create
these fake news press releases saying
that
you know i might pick um i might pick gt
here who's on my team manages my forms
i'd say gt
has won the former administrator of the
year and he beat out
millions of people worldwide and the
celebrity judge panel of you know jay-z
and president obama all agree that he
was the hands-down candidate so just
like a fun
fun video or fun message not not
following up on any kind of business
opportunities
and i'll do that with people in my life
and then the two businesses i've
invested in my
own and trying to dance salsa and then
my top client so i just keep this list a
pretty simple excel list that'll look at
once a quarter
and uh send off something fun to that's
the only
only way that i keep in touch with uh my
key contacts because the rest of it is
producing amazing content
that drives traffic and drives customers
to my business
so thanks for the great question
hopefully i've answered it
and uh andrew if you have any more
questions everybody else watching it
you know please give it a thumbs up
below let me know what you think leave a
comment
ask a question click on my face to
subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you guys soon thank you so
much for watching
you